so let me just introduce myself so
that's me and basically the introduction
that Pete provided as summarized here so
let me skip through that I also just
wanted to quickly mention galvanizes
data engineering immersive program so we
have a couple of people who graduated
from it sitting in the back and it's
just a couple of blocks down the street
we cover SPARC Hadoop Kafka storm and
andro constantly looking at new
technologies as well that have an uptake
in the market and will include them in
the curriculum here's just a little
matrix of all the different things we
cover and this is if you want more
information just go to galvanize or talk
to me or if you have any other questions
so so let's get into the talk so that's
like a little soft pitch I have to do in
order to be up here so otherwise I'll
get in trouble with Jared
that's a V so the talk today is about
Apache Kudo so you know you might as
peoples wondering you are probably
wondering as well what is what is the
CUDA what what exactly is Apache CUDA
and then how can we use this like what
what is it what is it all about so I
just wanted to get an idea of where
people are at just so I can kind of talk
at the right level so how many people
here are familiar with HDFS pretty much
everybody okay good and then what about
HBase all right good
so so you in some ways you actually
already know exactly how CUDA works you
basically just take those two things put
them together and that's that's kudu so
and then kudu I think Pete did a little
survey and there was one person who has
left so I think that's this part we have
we don't have a lot of kudu experts so
this is a kudu and it's a kind of
antelope that is found in eastern and
southern Africa and I think the
motivation behind the name is it's
something that's fast so it's fast and
lean and so in order to get to what
problem is trying to solve this really
two different concepts we have
to touch on first the first is latency
and the other is to put so latency is
basically how long it takes for
something to start up so you might have
something that goes really fast but if
it takes it a while to start up
sometimes it's not a good choice and so
in that case it has a high latency so
between airplanes and cars which would
you say has a higher latency airplanes
yeah so cars have a lower latency so the
winner is cars I mean generally you're
looking for lower latency laura's better
hires worse so the throughput is the
opposite so higher throughput is better
Laura's worse and through Perez
conceptually it's like how much can you
get done within a unit of time so it
could be a number of operations per
minute or per second but it could just
be the amount of work and so let's just
continue with the same analogy if you
just think of work as like people
getting transported which has higher
throughput airplanes or car so airplanes
right
and so airplanes definitely have higher
throughput and they transport more
people over longer distances than cars
can in the same amount of time and so
you can see this is a little matrix so
you have cars here airplanes here so
cars have low latency but also low
throughput airplanes have high latency
so you have to take some time till I get
through all the lines and everything but
then every once you're in things were
really fast and the jetpacks might be
like high throughput so this is like the
perfect sweet spot where you can strap
them on and just fly to LA and then
horses might be take a while to like
saddle up and they're also going to be
slower than cars so this is kind of the
worst corner on the matrix and generally
it's not the case that one is better and
the others worse and it really depends
on what your goal is so if you're if
we're going to Oakland generally driving
is going to be what you want to do and
then you so you you're fine with low
throughput you care more about low
latency but then if we're going to
Florida you want to fly
so now let's step back so just keep
those two things in mind and then let's
just step back to see why HBase exists
what problems it solves that HDFS had
and then also why Park Hae exists and so
basically kudu is a combination of HBase
and park' so HBase exists because HDFS
is immutable so it doesn't let you
modify records or data once you've
written it out so you can only append to
it and also it doesn't HDFS doesn't let
you read and write doesn't do random
access very fast so HBase lets you
access any key that you want and get the
value also it lets you do modifications
to the data so it has low latency
whereas HDFS has high latency right so
it takes a while to set things out and
then Park Hae is another technology that
it's basically a file format that sits
on top of HDFS and the main idea here is
columnar storage so you want to store by
columns so this lets you scan through
the data very fast it has high
throughput which is good so once you're
once you've set your MapReduce job up
its gonna go really fast once the data
starts coming in but the latency is also
high because HDFS just takes a while to
set things up you have to talk to the
name node and talk to various different
nodes over the network and so this is
essentially the same matrix so Parque
has high throughput but high latency and
then HBase has low latency but
relatively low throughput so if you ever
run hive on HBase it's much lower than
hive on HDFS so kudu kind of sits in
this corner or the generally it's worse
than both of these in their areas of
strength but it's good enough in both of
those areas and then in addition to that
it also is gives you both things at the
same time and then this is just
something that is on HDFS maybe not as
efficient as Park Hae would give you
high latency but also lower throughput
than park' so one way to think about
kudo is that it's HBase with columnar
storage they imagine HBase except
instead of storing your data in these
really wide rows you're storing it in
columnar Park here like storage so what
this means is you can scan through the
data much faster than you can of the
HBase so you can essentially run
MapReduce against kudu and get similar
speeds to Park Hae and at the same time
think of you can also think of kudu as
like mutable Park Hae so you're storing
this columnar data but you can also
modify it records and you also have
random access readwrite so it's kind of
like perky like HBase or HBase like
Parque and so there is a specific use
case and there's this reason this comes
up a lot so a lot of times you have
systems where you have data that's
historical that's sitting there and then
you have data that's coming in in real
time and you want to be able to
integrate them and so frequently what
happens is you end up with something
like a lambda architecture where you
have the data that's real time a sitting
in HBase because that's faster to write
to and then the data that's historical
is sitting in HDFS and possibly in a
park a format and so with kudu you can
by combining both of these things you
can essentially use kudu to store all of
your data as well as to in real time as
well as your historical data and so you
have all of your data in the same place
and then you can earn queries on it
combining data from both of those
sources and so it has fast columnar
scans so it competes with Parque there
also it has low latency random access so
it competes with HBase so this is kind
of a little picture that shows where
it's Dench it's not quite as good as
either one of these but it's it does a
trade-off between them so you end up
with decent performance on both of these
axes and also it's written in C++ this
wrappers for Java and Python it's very
early so it's its beta I'm gonna do a
little demo at the end so it does work
but it's but many of the pieces are
still promises like if you
through their documentation they have
little asterisks there next to things
but I still think it's worth keeping an
eye on and it's good to know what what's
going on with this because it has a lot
of potential yeah yeah you know this is
something that so I used to work at
Cloudera so with some of the people on
this and I think with open-source
software it's nobody can estimate it let
alone people are not even working on the
code so I I have no idea but I think
even the people who are actually doing
check-ins on github have no idea when it
will have those features but they have
they have some kind of a timeline and I
think it'll depend on how many people
contribute and how much traction it gets
I think your guess is gonna be as good
as mine but maybe I let me just say here
why not
hopefully no one's recording this Yeah
right
I think the recently maybe you know did
a big release and at the same time it is
somewhat usable so I think it's not past
probably useful as stable enough to be
in production but you can start
experimenting with it so I feel like I
think it's gaining more traction so I
see more activity on the mailing list
and on their community sites so here are
some benchmarks and so you can see that
with Parque it's a little bit worse on
these key PCH benchmark numbers and so
this is a so Kudo is orange and lore is
better so on some of these benchmarks
it's lower but on some it's slightly
higher so it's basically on about on par
with parque but possibly slightly worse
and then with HBase it's we're comparing
throughput and certain throughput as
well it's HBase is better so CUDA is not
quite as good so it's basically like
just bad at everything but it's it's
slightly bad instead of being really bad
which HBase and
hdfs are by themselves and then this is
an interesting chart because this
compares kudo against Phoenix Oh Phoenix
is the fastest sequel you can get on
HBase it's it's written it was written
by Salesforce as part it's an Apache
product now but it it's really intended
to kind of use all the tricks that HBase
provides in order to squeeze as much
performance art of sequel as possible
and so on
comparing kuta with phoenix and with
parque on HDFS you can see that and
impalas being used for kudo and parque
so so Phoenix and Kudo are about have
about the same performance I mean in
some cases kuda is actually slightly
better and then parque is significantly
better on sequel like processing but
kudo is is actually comparable to parque
in most of these so this is a primary
use case for why kudu where kuda would
make sense so generally if you're just
using it for storage HDFS will work fine
but when you have real-time data and
historical data then in the past without
kudu you essentially have these two
parallel systems and you have to
integrate the data between them if you
want to run a query against the newer
data and the older data so the end
actually let me just move on to this use
case so for example if you are an online
retailer you want to both look at what
products have been selling for the last
week and last month but you also want to
know what's selling today so there might
be a certain rush on a specific product
so you want to make sure to pick up on
that and you want to keep track of
inventory so you can resupply and maybe
place more orders but at the same time
you also want to show the more popular
products on top of your bestsellers page
so people buy more of the hot selling
product instead of assuming your site
doesn't offer it so in this case you
have historical data which you don't
want to throw away you don't want to
just completely be
be at the whim of like the fad that's
going on in the last 10 minutes but you
also don't want to be completely stuck
with trends that stretch out over you
know the last month or last year and so
you want to integrate both of these
sources so you end up with the
historical data being in HDFS and the a
real time data being in HBase and then
your queries have to merge both of those
datasets together
so with kuru you can essentially merge
them into Kudo and in fact so before
kuru you'd have two parallel
architectures but then with Kudo you can
just store your historical data in CUDA
as well as your real-time incoming data
into kudou and then your architecture
actually becomes a lot more streamlined
so you don't have to even know what
lambda architecture was and it can just
just turn into like this sort of bad
memory of an architecture that people
once used to use to use so your data
just comes in and you just run queries
on CUDA so let's see I think we're doing
okay on time so I'll just go into the
internals a little bit and so this is
the architecture of kuru now one of the
first things about kudu is that it does
not sit on HDFS so HBase is a layer on
top of HDFS that gives you mute ability
so you can write rows in to HBase and
then modify them and all of that happens
in memory or it keeps a log of the
changes and so when you do a query you
get the latest value of your of your
cells so kuru doesn't depend on each
HDFS it actually writes directly to disk
so it's it's it's in fact independent of
Hadoop it can just run by itself without
a dupe and also in fact the architecture
has some similarities with Kafka so you
have a there's a master tablet and then
there's all these tablet servers which
are kind of like regent servers from
HBase and then there's a mass there's a
leader and follower paradigm that that
it uses for replication so let's talk
about the master first so the master has
some fault tolerance you can
multiple masters the other masters do
not respond to requests from clients
they're just there to be a backup in
case the leader or master fails or fails
and so in that case they'll they'll
elect a new leader and then that's gonna
serve client requests so they follow the
leader and then whatever updates the
leader makes to its metadata they make
as well and raft is a protocol that they
use both for electing leaders as well as
for maintaining consistency so here are
some of the roles that the master has so
keeps track of the metadata figures out
who's alive and then also keeps track of
the tablets so regions are called
tablets going back to the terminology of
like BigTable from Google and so all the
regions are basically tablets and these
are all tablet servers so one of the
differences between HBase and kuru is
that the tables are statically
partitioned into tablets so when you do
a create table command at that point you
specify how many tablets you're gonna
have so it doesn't increase the number
of regions or decreased based on how
much data there is so you have to kind
of make a decision right at the
beginning also you can choose
replication factors of three and five
and the replication again uses the
leader follow a pattern for consensus so
the leader is the only one who's allowed
to write and so anytime the leader
accepts a write request it propagates it
to its followers and then if everyone
reaches a consensus then they accept
that right and then otherwise the write
fails the followers are able to serve
read request but not write requests
so yeah so that rights must be done on
the on the leader actually that I think
there's a typo here and then reads can
be on leaders or followers and then
basically they only replicate the right
logs everybody keeps writing all
modifications and then each tablets are
responsible for maintaining the state in
a combination of memory and this on its
own so they don't need to worry about
getting all that the client has metadata
about which tablet lives where so
interest automatically talks to the
leader for the tablet that wants to
modify and if it's wrong then it'll just
at that party refreshes its cache on the
internals are similar to HBase as well
so basically you have these as a memory
each tablet as a piece where it stores a
component where stores grows in memory
and then periodically come back start to
disk and then over time T's get
compacted as well and I'll each time
that if there's a modification on any of
these rows that have already been read
not to this then there's a delta mem mem
store which keeps track of that in
memory and then so it tries to keep all
the all the records for a specific role
in the same disk grow set which includes
deltas as well as the initial write and
this is a coop paper that's white paper
that's on their site that goes into all
the details of Enoch and Charles also
the tablets are based on the static
partition that you do right at the
beginning so you can either specify a
hashed partition or you can also do a
range partition so we'll try the range
partition in a demo like shortly so I
think this will make more sense but you
can either just hash
software columns into partitions so that
big
a shower or they or the partition can be
done by you just sent some keys to a
specific partition and meaning specific
tablet and secluded does not require to
do in order to be fast and if this has
no dependency on any of these pieces at
the same time the easiest way to
interact with an mr. Impala so they've
added some quick of policy to talk to
who and so even though on the African
savannah news and compositor get along
in a new cluster they get along really
well and so general bear their best
practice they recommend is to just run
to do with ETFs you can set aside some
district space for doing and some for
HDFS and also you can cool Pasadena
localities if you're in MapReduce or
spark they will run on the same which
means where the where the tablet is
stored that your average javis been a
concern the other thing that's different
about crew is that it has a static
schema so I'm like HBase which is the
complete no sequel which has no single
schema where you can add columns up on
the fly who do requires that you specify
it cause much like the relational
database and so it supports these
primitive types and also the cells have
to be small so generally their
recommendation is to stay below 10
kilobytes so this is not really
Tenderfoot blobs or images but more
purchase records where you have most of
your column values in the cell itself
yeah
these are her these are individual
values and so the in the current lease
they might not even work but in general
it's not intended to work for very long
for very large values so these are all
those common values and then also this
different including type so you can
specify on the schema and this kind of
squeezes the columnar metaphor even
further so clean inputting is the
default you can also do bit shuffle and
putting for integers and other bitwise
other bits oriented fields and
essentially this is like columnar
including 4 bits so what it does is it
just takes the it soars the most
significant bit first than the second
most significant so if you have a lot of
values which are pretty similar with
just some variation of the least
significant bits then you'll be able to
compact to store them break through
faculty so you'll end up when you
compress them you'll have a lot of
repetition and then also run length
encoding is supported on fields if you
have this is something where chaos as
well and kind of this part of the secret
sauce of arcade so if you have the same
ip address repeated 100 times they'll
just be store once and also this is
something that's particularly useful for
big data there's a lot of times the data
is not normalized and so you're looking
at the log files and other data sources
where you have the same values for most
of the columns and so we run that length
encoding you can just just make the data
much more compact but also the scans are
not going to be faster we're just going
to read this
you'll pick up off valleys and there's
also a couple of other types benefiting
the dictionary prefix and also you can
enable compression and compression is
it's a choice that you can make and it
kind of has this trade-off that it will
shrink down your space but it won't
increase your performance whereas
running up and putting will generally
attempt to make things faster all right
so I think people are less out great 30
so I think we'll be able to blend us on
time so you know demo next and support
the demo actually we just go through the
slides first
so for the demo you have to download the
plugin Eric Cooke's car BM now who the
works on some other things as well but
that's like the best arm to kind of try
it out first and also when you install
and it comes up in VirtualBox so you
just have to open up a port so that you
can look at the admin view is also one
of the nice things about to do is it's
written by people who were on the
professional services team and clutter
so they have a lot of experience with
colon shooting and debugging so they've
built in monitoring and nice web UI is
for Advent so then you can see what's
going on and so this is even just some
settings you have to do on VirtualBox to
open up the admin UI port and so the
admin UI runs on 8:05 1 and then after
that you NASA stage into the Quick Start
machine if it's running on on VirtualBox
with user as user demo and then the
password is also down and you start a
polished out and then after that you
create a table not the interesting thing
here is you so we're creating a table
with stained IDs sale dated store
product amount and and this is an
example of creating
tablets by the using arrange these are
Biscay of using arranged partition
instead of hash partition so the syntax
perhaps partitioning is well ready to
specify that the clock should be hashed
and based on that the tablets will
create so this is going to split up your
keys it's going to put these split
points so it's been here for five months
so everything before California to
California and then between 5 20 at
Washington and our actually between
tough when you're Oregon and Oregon and
Washington and then after then you can
insert some data into it and then just
run regular sequel and then you want to
look at it in the QuickStart UI so I've
actually run all these things already
and I was so I'm just gonna I think the
inserted actually the unfortunate girls
with dunce I'm going to just do a select
so I'm already and actually just at
least do this part so I'm going to test
the state you too
oh you know what I didn't realize but I
think it should be okay I don't have
Wi-Fi but I won't have on my local
machine
maybe I wasn't a good idea okay so let
me just see if this works
oh yes this is working so the web UI is
working and so the only thing is you
have to type in Polish silencer Kampala
because that's that's what the shell is
called and now I can do things like show
tables and so I currently have one table
to sales I can do describe sales and so
you can see it has exactly the structure
that we expect and also you do to
describe formatted sales if well yeah so
this is a wraparound you can see it has
all of humanity that we passed in
through still so it has a cool table
name and a guru master address and all
the food specific fields and so now I
can run
yes now I can just run some of me so the
data is should already be there and I
can I can just run select account thanks
let me save this one stop so I can do
select account star sales and so you can
see that has six elements and I can also
do select star from sales just to see
what they are so these are all the six
records that I inserted and then
anything around basically any query that
impulse reports on this so the only
difference here is it's sort of hitting
Part A which Apollo would normally do
this is interacting with ku and so
you're getting comparable performance to
what you get with our K at the same time
using the Java API you are also able to
do gets inputs and scans just like HP's
on the same data so that's time for the
big benefit and then we can
you can look at the web UI you haven't
UI which is just on port 80 51 and this
has tables and so this is another table
which actually I delete it but I dropped
but it's still showing up there some art
or why why that is if you go to the
sales table you can see that has four
tablets which are based on the ranges
that I specified and and then this is
kind of the only one tablet server and
this these are all the different metrics
that so there are some command line
tools as well that give you the that you
can use to extract metrics directly from
right actually that's a good question or
it doesn't that's actually I'm not sure
offhand so I would have to yes it does I
mean in general though when you make
queries it only since this storage is
calmer it doesn't actually scan all the
columns it's only gonna go to the
specific column that you're looking for
and also but then the those files when
it stores the files on disk it will
store it stores each column in a
separate blocks right I mean storing it
in a columnar way since it's a big file
but it has as he was a columns bar from
the first from the set of rows and a
second set of elements on the second
clause
so in general it should not have a I
mean sure agreed a high number of
positive you can happen that's something
I'll have to attack and I think it will
require some white field experience is
always like using this right now my
favorite mentally might be much better
than where this right now so I think the
white grouper is actually pretty good it
goes into a lot of the details for the
QuickStart p.m. you can get the steps
here and try to start the schema
document just talks about the way you
can create tables and I'm specifying the
different encoding schemes and then the
hutong polygon is also pretty useful so
I just wanted to just have a slide bar
didn't turn program again and I just
open it up to questions
why you write eccentric and each as I
used each basin in here as the foil for
like the you know low latency databases
but Cassandra HBase are very similar so
Cassandra always have the same issue
where they're they're good act random
access and also to give you credibility
but they're not they're not going to
give you this but your for any analytics
part is gonna be faster money to be fast
because if you're an eye for example
it's going to be much faster so high I
guess on the Sundering difference see
yes cql or something like that but it's
still going to be it's not going to be
as fast as pre-k so the main the main
advantage is it's kind of giving you
both accommodation so Sandra and HBase
are you know there are some differences
in the performance but overall they're
their architectures with summer
any other questions I think Pete might
have some more can openers anyone wants
all right all right